♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
MOB RULE AND LEFT WING
INTIMIDATION IS ONCE AGAIN THAT
FASHIONABLE INSIDE THE MODERN
EXTREME DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY AFTER FIRST IGNORING AND
EXCUSING AND IN SOME CASES EVEN
OPENLY BEING SUPPORTIVE OF THE
574 VIOLENT RIOTS IN THE SUMMER
OF 2020, DOZENS DEAD, THOUSANDS
OF COPS INJURED, BILLIONS IN
PROPERTY DAMAGE.
PEOPLE LIKE KAMALA HARRIS
PROVIDING A BAIL FUND TO
MINNESOTA AND THE DEFUNDING
EFFORTS THERE.
AND THEN OF COURSE
HYPOCRITICALLY SPENDING EVERY
WAKING MOMENT OF EVERY DAY
OBSESSIVELY CONDEMNING THE RIOT
ON JANUARY 6TH.
AND OF COURSE, IGNORING THE CORE
ISSUE OF WHY NANCY PELOSI AND
MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER FAILED TO
MAKE USE OF THE UP TO 20,000
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD AUTHORIZED AS
REQUIRED BY LAW TWO DAYS PRIOR
TO KEEP THE PEACE.
AS ALSO REQUESTED BY THE CAPITOL
POLICE CHIEF REPEATEDLY.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW REVERSING
COURSE ONCE AGAIN AND THEY ARE
SUPPORTING ACTS OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE.
AS WE SPEAK, FOR A LOVED ARE
TRYING TO HARASS AND INTIMIDATE
U.S. SUPREME COURT JUSTICES AND
COERCE THEM INTO SAVING
ROE V. WADE.
IT IS A DISGUSTING, DESPICABLE
ATTEMPT TO DESTROY THE
INDEPENDENCE OF OUR NATIONS
JUDICIARY.
AND THE SILENCE AND THE TASK
APPROVAL FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND JOE BIDEN AND
DEMOCRATS FRANKLY, THAT IS
EQUALLY REPULSIVE.
THIS WEEK JUSTICE ALITO AND HIS
FAMILY WERE FORCED TO FLEE THEIR
HOME AFTER WRITERS DON'T LIKE
RIOTERS A PUBLISHER'S ADDRESS
AND MADE PLANS TO SHOW UP AT HIS
FRONT DOOR.
BY THE WAY, THEY SHOWED UP.
SARA CARTER WILL JOIN US LIVE
FROM THE SCENE, THE SO-CALLED
DEMONSTRATION THAT JUST TOOK
PLACE OUTSIDE OF ALITO'S HOME.
SADLY IT IS NOT JUST
JUSTICE ALITO.
MULTIPLE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
AND THEIR FAMILIES WERE TARGETED
AT THEIR OWN HOMES BY
PRO-ABORTION ACTIVISTS.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
THIS IS NEVER OKAY.
THEY MUST BE SAVED, MUST BE
PROTECTED FROM POLITICAL
VIOLENCE AND INTIMIDATION,
BECAUSE IT IS NEVER ACCEPTABLE.
ON THE SHOW WE CONDEMN ALL OF
THE WRITING COME ALL 574 RIOTS
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020.
WE CONDEMN VIOLENCE ON
JANUARY 6TH.
I DID AT REAL TIME ON OWN RADIO
SHOW AND ON THE SHOW.
WE CONDEMNS THE LEFT'S VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE SUPREME COURT AND
PRO-LIFE AMERICANS EVERYWHERE.
OVER THE WEEKEND IN WISCONSIN,
THE HEADQUARTERS OF A PRO-LIFE
GROUP WAS ATTACKED, A MOLOTOV
COCKTAIL THROWN THROUGH A WINDOW
INTO AN OFFICE CAUSING
CONSIDERABLE DAMAGE AND LOOK AT
YOUR SCREEN, THIS THREATENING
MESSAGE WAS SPRAY-PAINTED ON THE
BUILDING.
"IF ABORTIONS AREN'T SAFE, THEN
YOU AREN'T EITHER."
A CHURCH IN COLORADO ALSO
DEFACED BY PRO-ABORTION VANDALS
AND DID NEW YORK, ST. PATRICK'S
CATHEDRAL WAS SURROUNDED BY
PROTESTERS HURLING INSULTS AT
ANYONE WHO WENT INSIDE.
AND IN LOS ANGELES, RIOTERS
DRESSED AS HANDMADE STORMED INTO
A CATHOLIC CHURCH SERVICE
SHOUTING PROFANITIES AND
PRO-ABORTION RHETORIC.
AND IN WASHINGTON, D.C., TO
CATHOLIC CHURCHES ON
CAPITOL HILL REQUESTED EXTRA
POLICE PRESENCE AFTER ONE LEFT
WING GROUP THREATENED TO "BURN
THE EUCHRE RECEPTACLE.
NATURALLY, MANY DEMOCRATS, THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
ARE APPLAUDING THIS KIND OF
VIOLENCE.
I GUESS THE ONLY CONDEMN
VIOLENCE IF THEY CAN TIE IT
SOMEHOW TO SOMETHING REPUBLICAN
OR CONSERVATIVE.
AND A STATEMENT THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE NANCY PELOSI APPLAUDED
THE SO-CALLED PROTESTERS WERE
USING THEIR RIGHTEOUS ANGER TO
MARCH AND TO MOBILIZE.
IN FRONT OF JUSTICES HOUSES.
AND GET THIS, ONE REPORTER
EXPLICITLY CALLED FOR MORE
VIOLENCE TWEETING A LINK TO THE
WISCONSIN ATTACK ALONG WITH THE
CAPTION "MORE OF THIS."
MAY THEY NEVER KNOW A MOMENT OF
PEACE OR SAFETY UNTIL THEY ROT
IN THE GROUND FOR THE WANNABE
POLITICIAN IN CALIFORNIA CALLED
FOR CAVANAUGH'S HOME AND ALL OF
HIS POSSESSIONS, THAT THEY BE
BURNED IN FRONT OF HIM HERE THE
RHETORIC ON TV WAS EVEN WORSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF VIOLENCE IS ALWAYS OVER
THE LINE.
THE REAL QUESTIONS AND
CONVERSATIONS TODAY ABOUT
PROTESTS OUTSIDE THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HAVE
STRICTLY JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THAT LINE IS.
>> AND CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU HAD
FOR OVER 50 YEARS ARE ABOUT TO
BE OVERTURNED.
>> THE JUSTICES DON'T LIKE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, THEY COULD JUST
DRIVE TO THE STATE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DETERMINED THAT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT FOR
PRIVACY.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
WOMEN TO DO.
IF THEY WANT TO CONTROL THEIR
BODIES, RIGHT?
>> ALL OF THESE THINGS WE SAY
MIGHT HAPPEN IF ABORTION GETS
BANNED, IF ABORTION BECOMES A
LEGAL, THEY DO HAPPEN.
THIS ISN'T A THEORY.
WE DON'T NEED TO SPECULATE.
WE HAVE ACTUAL FACTS THAT CAN
INFORM WHAT HAPPENED.
>> ABORTION IS NOT GETTING
BANNED AND IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
A LEGAL PAIR THAT IS A BIG LIE.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN THE
SECOND.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT ACTUALLY
GETS WORSE.
ONE PERSON SAYING, SHE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE LOVE TO THE
SUPREME COURT LEADER AND THEN
JOYFULLY ABORT THE FETUS.
WE WILL PLAY THAT DISTURBING
CLIP COMING UP.
BUT MAYBE WORST OF ALL, FOR MORE
THAN A WEEK THE WHITE HOUSE
COMPLETELY UTTERLY REFUSED TO
CONDEMN WHAT IS THE STOCKING AND
OUTRIGHT INTIMIDATION ONTO
DOXXING OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
LISTEN TO JEN PSAKI REPEATEDLY
EXCUSING AND SUPPORTING THE
PROTEST AT THE HOMES OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES WHERE
THEY HAVE CHILDREN AND THEY HAVE
FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES AND
NEIGHBORS.
REALLY?
YOU SUPPORT THIS, JOE?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU THINK THE THREATS OF
ACTIVISTS THAT ARE PLANNING
OUTSIDE OF JUSTICES HOUSES ARE
EXTREME?
>> PEACEFUL PROTEST?
NO.
NOT EXTREME.
>> THEIR NEIGHBORS ARE NOT ALL
PUBLIC FIGURES.
BUT WITH THE PRESIDENT THINK
ABOUT WAVING OFF ACTIVISTS THAT
WANT TO GO --
>> I DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL U.S.
GOVERNMENT POSITION ON WHERE
PEOPLE PROTEST.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE IF
CONSERVATIVES START GIVING OUT
THE ADDRESSES OF PROMINENT
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS AND SAYING, GO
PROTEST IN FRONT OF THEIR HOUSE,
DO IT PEACEFULLY.
THAT WOULD BE OKAY?
AFTER A WEEKEND OF VIOLENCE,
JEN PSAKI WAS FORCED TO ISSUE
THIS TEPID STATEMENT TO THE
PRESIDENT STRONGLY BELIEVES IN
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PROTEST, BUT THAT SHOULD NEVER
INCLUDE VIOLENCE, THREATS, OR
VANDALISM.
JUDGES PERFORM AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FUNCTION IN OUR
SOCIETY AND THEY MUST BE ABLE TO
DO THEIR JOBS WITHOUT CONCERN
FOR THE PERSONAL SAFETY.
SO WHY DON'T YOU TELL YOUR
SUPPORTERS, JOE, TO STAY AWAY
FROM THEIR PRIVATE HOMES?
AND JEN, WHAT ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED PROTESTERS STALKING
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES AT HOME.
CARE TO SAY ANYTHING ABOUT THAT?
APPARENTLY NOT.
>> PEACEFULLY PROTESTING OUTSIDE
THE HOMES OF JUDGES AND
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
THERE IS A LAW IN VIRGINIA THAT
ACTUALLY PROHIBITS PRIVATE
RESIDENCE, EVEN WHEN IT'S DONE
PEACEFULLY.
I'M WONDERING IF ANY SORT OF
DEMONSTRATION -- DO THEY FOLLOW
THAT LAW?
>> WE ARE CERTAINLY NOT
SUGGESTING ANYONE BREAK ANY
LAWS.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S VIEW HAS LONG BEEN,
AND I TWEETED THIS EARLIER THIS
MORNING AND REPEATED AND MADE A
NUMBER OF COMMENTS.
VIOLENCE, THREATS, AND
INTIMIDATION HAVE NO PLACE IN
POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
>> Sean: I'M SURE IF SOMETHING
HAPPENED YOU WOULD PROBABLY CALL
IT AN INSURRECTION, RIGHT?
DO YOU REALLY THINK -- DO YOU
REALLY CARE THAT SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES ARE GETTING STALKED,
HARASSED, INTIMIDATED THIS WAY?
YOU CARE ABOUT CHURCHES BEING
VANDALIZED AS WE WITNESS THIS
WEEKEND.
IMAGINE IF WE FLIPPED THE
SCRIPT.
IMAGINE IF CONSERVATIVES WERE
STALKING, HARASSING LIBERAL
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES, WHICH
THEY NEVER SHOULD DO.
COULD YOU IMAGINE THE OUTRAGE?
IMAGINE THE HYSTERIA, THE
HYPOCRISY IS OFF THE CHARTS
HERE.
OF COURSE, DEMOCRATS -- THEY ARE
ALL HYPOCRITES, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ALMOST NO PRINCIPLES.
THEY WERE VIRTUALLY SILENT WITH
574 RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF 2020,
BUT THEY DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE ONE RIGHT, BECAUSE THEY CAN
USE IT FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
THINK ABOUT THIS, FOR SEVERAL
YEARS, DEMOCRATS TRIED TO
WEAPONIZE YOUR GOVERNMENT AND
FORCE ALL AMERICANS TO GET
VACCINATED, THEN BOOSTER TO
COME, BOOSTED AGAIN, EVEN THOUGH
WE HAVE BREAKTHROUGH CASES.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS LOST THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE OF THAT MANDATE.
MILLIONS MORE WERE TURNED AWAY
FROM RESTAURANTS.
MY BODY, MY CHOICE DIDN'T SEEM
TO EXIST TO THE LEFT WHEN IT
CAME TO VACCINES.
THAT SAME PRINCIPLE -- WE ARE
NOT GOING TO APPLY THAT TO
ABORTION?
STILL AT THE OF THE DAY COME
ABORTION WILL BE LEGAL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
ALL THE HYSTERIA, ALL THE
HYPERBOLE IS FULL'S, EVEN IF
ROE V. WADE IS OVERTURNED.
THE IDEA THAT -- IF IT WILL
SOMEHOW END ABORTION IN AMERICA,
IT IS NOW THE BIG DEMOCRATIC
LIVE.
DEMOCRATS NEED A GOOD
DISTRACTION FOR THE MIDTERMS, A
WAY TO DRIVE OUT TURN OUT AND
EXCITE THEIR BASE AND
THEORETICAL BASE IS LAPPI